salut je m'appelle vincent et elle c'est
isabelle
ça aurait pu marcher entre nous même a
quitté pour ce type c'est dégoûtant quoi
ça va c'est la nature
et puis il ya eu une attaque avec elle
c'était le grand amour mais elle aussi
est parti et devinez avec qui ça veut
dire qu'en face expliqué deux fois une
fois ça peut arriver une fois c'est
normal et deux fois pour vieux là j'ai
pas possible tu as vu la dégaine kg et
mange mais seuls épices par tout ce qui
est un truc avec les fans quand je
t'aime j'ai l'impression d'être un
disque rousseau d'autrefois
aujourd'hui je suis avec la nar et
pourtant je continue à me prendre la
tête
et qu'est ce qu'elle trouve tout à ce
type est une plein de pognon son nom
buzz bien je te rassure un question
taille vous étiez tous les deux moyennes
basses font leurs valises
bon bah si tu veux dire ma foi du tour
dû sortir avec un mec comme ça à faire
qu'ils fassent ce qu une troisième fois
on l'a pas du tout denis salut à la
bombe à
au point
en même temps j'ai peut-être fait une
erreur en essayant de comprendre une
couleur est la chute que tu as fait
avant même chance de cocu fait par tous
bah oui on rigolait bawa télécom va
piquer pour qu il l a baisé chez moi